boy oh boy  the price of freedom is steep  zach speaking making progress zach  angel  i can cut loose right  within reason  it's show time  [Music]  soldier first class genesis  a month ago  he went missing during a mission in  wutai you know i've never actually seen  you use that don't you think it's sort  of a waste  use brings about wear tear and rust and  that's a real waste  [Music]  project g gave birth to the man we know  as genesis  project g  [Music]  project  genesis  settle down  zack the puppy  what do you know  [ __ ] relax dogs  [Music]  [Music]  hello  heaven  not quite  it's a church  by the way what is your dream  to become first  is it  no  to become a hero  oh good  unattainable dreams are the best kind  [Music]  embrace your dreams  and  whatever happens  protect your honor  as soldier  come and get it  [Music]  you